♪ [music] ♪
- [male] We are the paradoxical ape,
bi-pedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable yet filed
with optimism. We grow up slowly, we hand
down knowledge, we empathize and deceive,
we shake the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Rachel] So I want to start this story
actually in the 1800s. So in 1800 a young
physician named Itard, decided to take on
the task of teaching a young boy French.
Turns out that this young boy, they think
was between 10 and 12 years old, he had no
language and he'd been discovered running
in the woods naked and unable to
communicate. Itard thought that this was a
very important task because he thought
that civilization was based on the ability
to empathize and also on language. So he
tried valiantly for two years to teach
this young boy named Victor, he named him
Victor because over this two year time
spent the only language that or sounds
that this young boy could make was the
French Er, which sounds like Victor and he
had his name. But after two years Victor
was unable to speak any French and
comprehended very little French and
primarily communicated with objects. And
then Itard wrote this up, after two years
he wrote up his findings and he said that
he thought that a major reason why Victor
didn't learn French was because he was
simply too old. But of course, this was
the 1800s and he didn't speculate as to
what it was about being 10 years old with
no language, that would prevent you from
learning language if you had a daily tutor
trying to teach you French. There's an
enormous amount of irony in this
particular story because Itard was the
house physician for the first school for
the deaf in the entire world and here we
have a picture of it. The first school for
the deaf was begun in 1760 in Paris and at
the time that Itard was teaching Victor,
he was at the school with all of these
children who use sign language and all of
these teachers who use sign language.
Nonetheless it never occurred to him, to
try to teach Victor sign language.
But we can't blame him because in the
1800s, sign language was not considered to
be a language. And in fact, that
particular discovery and realization
wouldn't happen for another century and a
half, and so we can imagine why he didn't
teach Victor sign language. The question
is, could Victor have actually learned
sign language if Itard had tried to teach
it to him? And so, I'm going to try to
answer that question today through a
series of studies. But before I talk about
our studies, I want to talk about
something that all of the speakers who
have preceded me have talked about, which
is that one thing that's the defining
characteristic of language is that it's
highly structured. And it's highly
structured at all of these multiple
levels, so that the speech sounds make up
words, words make up words and phonemes
and these words are strung together in
sentences with syntax, and this specific
syntax helps us understand and produce
very specific kinds of meanings.
Now one aspect of this language structure
is that humans have evolved to the point
where children learn this structure
naturally, nobody has to teach them,
nobody has to have a tutor to sit with
them for two years, to teach them the
structure of French or the structure of
English, or the structure of ASL. Simply
by being around people who use a language,
young children naturally acquire all of
these multi-leveled and complicated
structure. That is to say all children do
this if in fact they can access the
language around them, if they have normal
hearing they're born with normal hearing,
they hear people talk and before you know
it they're talking themselves. But if
children are born profoundly deaf, they
cannot hear the speech around them and we
know that lip reading is insufficient to
learn language because most of the speech
sounds are invisible. What happens to
these children if there's no sign language
in the environment, they can't learn a
visual form of language either.
So it happens that there are large numbers
of children who actually are like Victor
in the sense that they grow up without
language, without learning a language but
they are unlike Victor in that they were
running around in the woods nude and
having a very harsh life. So how does a
lack of language in childhood affect the
ability to learn language or does it
affect ability to learn language? And this
has been the focus of studies that we have
been doing for many years in our
laboratory. Because we're using deaf
children and sign language is a means some
model, language acquisition and its effect
on the brain. I think it's appropriate
that I talk a little bit about the kinds
of stimuli we do and about American Sign
Language. So first of all, you should know
that American sign language unlike many
the sign languages that have been
discussed up to this point is a very
sophisticated language, it's evolved
clearly over 200 years. You might even say
that American sign language evolved with
the development of the United States of
America and spread as civilization went
across, as white man went across the
continent.
So American Sign Language has a
phonological system and more phonological
system syntax and so forth. So for those
of you who don't know sign, I know there
are many people here who didn't know sign,
I want to show you what some of this
structure looks like. So I'm going to play
you two video tapes and for those of you
who don't know sign, I would like you to
guess which one is syntactically
structured, and for those of you who do
know sign, maybe you could keep the answer
to yourselves.
That's one, here's two.
So how many think two? How many think one?
Okay, for those of you who think 2, I
captioned this. So this is really Kon dird
lun blid mackers gancakes. Number 1 is
A fully formed sentence with a subordinate
clause. The reason I'm showing you these
two sentences is for those of you who
don't know the language, you can't
perceive or parse this particular
structure. This is what knowing a language
is about. For those of you who know ASL
and who know this language, you know that
the second example had all of these signs
which were non-signs, possible signs but
really just non-signs. This is part of
what knowing language is about, how do
people learn this particular structure and
the question that we're interested in
this, how does being a young child help
people learn this particular structure? So
we did a series of experiments, when we
started this work it wasn't even clear
that age would make a difference in sign
language acquisition. Sign language is
gestural, sign language is mimetic maybe
anybody can learn sign language at any
time in their lives.
So in one experiment what we did is we
recruited a number of people, this is in
Canada, who are born deaf and who use ASL
and we asked them, we created an
experiment where we had a set of sentences
that varied in complexity and we showed
them these ASL sentences, and we asked
them simply to point to a picture that
reflected the meaning of the sentence that
they saw. And we were quite struck by our
findings, what you see here is that deaf
people who learned ASL from birth, from
their parents perform very very well in
this task. In contrast to deaf people who
were adults who've been signing for over
20 years performed at chance.
So they had great difficulty understanding
some of these basic sentences in ASL. So
this suggest that there are age of
acquisition effects for sign as they are
for spoken language, everybody sort of the
word on the street is it's much harder to
learn a language if you're an adult than
if you're a child. But what if it's
something deeper than this? What if
there's something about learning a
language in childhood that sets up the
ability to learn language that creates the
ability to learn language? And so we did
another experiment also in Canada, but we
decided in order to test this particular
hypothesis we should switch languages. So
we're no longer testing ASL here, what
we're testing here is English we devised
an experiment in English where we had a
setup sentences and some of them are
ungrammatical and some of them were
grammatical. This is a common kind of task
that's psycho-linguists use.
And notice here that the people who were
born profoundly deaf, and for whom ASL was
a first language are near native in
English. So this is a second language, so
learning a language early even though it's
in sign helps people learn a second
language, and notice also that their
performance was indistinguishable from
normally hearing people who had learned
other languages at birth, German, Urdu,
Spanish and French. So there seems to be
that there's something about learning a
language early in life regardless of
whether it's a sign language or a spoken
language that actually helps people learn
more language. It's not simply learning
language when one is little. But as also
part of this experiment we tested a group
of individuals who've been signing for 20
years and had gone through the educational
system in Canada who were born deaf. And
on this task they performed at chance. In
the grammaticality judgment task it's
either yes or no, so it's a chance. So we
see that individuals who are deprived of
language, who aren't able to learn
language at a young age performed poorly
on their primary language sign language
and they perform very poorly on a second
language which is ASL and we see the
reverse.
So there's something really special going
on here about learning language at an
early age and what might this be and might
it be in the brain? So in another set of
studies, what we did is take this
population that we have been looking at
and we decided to neural image their
language processing. To see whether this
might give us some clues to differences
between first and second language learners
and people who had language and people who
did not have language. So in this study
also done in Canada with colleagues at the
Montreal Neurological Institute, we did
MRI or FMRI and maybe many of you have had
MRI's. And we showed the subjects
sentences like the sentences that you saw
and we ask them to make grammatical
judgments on these sentences. And we
tested 22 people, they were all born
profoundly deaf, they all used American
Sigh Language as a primary language, they
had all gone through the educational
system but they ranged in the age of which
they were first able to acquire language,
this is all the way from birth up to age
14.
So if the age at which you learn your
first language doesn't make a difference,
then we should expect the neural
processing patterns of all of these
individuals to be similar. If age of
acquisition makes a difference, we should
see different patterns in the brain and in
fact this is what we found. When we did
the analysis, we found that there were
seven regions in the brain primarily in
the left hemisphere and as you know now
the left hemisphere has areas that are
responsible for language. And one fact
that we found was that in the language
regions of the left hemisphere, the
earlier the person learned their first
language the more activation we saw in the
language hemisphere. However, the older
the person was when they learned their
first language, the less activation we got
in the language areas of the brain.
So if there's less activation, is there
something else going on here? And we
actually found a second effect which we
were not expecting at all, which is in the
back part of the brain, the posterior part
of the brain, in visual processing which
is this particular effect was that the
longer the person matured without
language, the older they were when they
learned language we found greater
activation, more neural resources being
devoted to visual processing. So we see
that here in this group of deaf signers we
have two complimentary reciprocal effects
of when a child learns his or her, when an
individual learns their first language and
what the brain seems to be doing in terms
of processing that language. So that for
people who learned language early in life
almost all of their neural resources are
devoted to processing the meaning and
structure of that language.
For people who learned their first
language later in life, more neural
resources are devoted to just trying,
perhaps to figure out what the signal was,
was it this'll work, was it glum or was it
gleam. So we have this reciprocal
relationship between perceptual processing
and language processing. This particular
pattern is not unique to deaf signers
there's work by Tim Brown and Schleger
that show that younger children often have
more posterior activation than older
children, and there are also some clinical
population such as autistic individuals.
Particularly those who's language skills
are not well developed, will often show
more processing in the occipital lobe, so
this is not a pattern that is unique to
deafness. So the next question we had is
whether in fact is, how does language
develop when an individual first starts to
learn it, when they're much older for
example, when they are a teen.
We have been very fortunate to have
followed five or six children in our
laboratory who had no language until they
were 13 to 14 years of age for a variety
of reasons. Two of these children are from
the United States, these other children
are from other countries. And actually,
this particular circumstance where we
might think of it as being very rare is
actually very common particularly in
underdeveloped countries. And so, the way
in which we have observed or analyzed the
language acquisition is to use normal
procedures that people used to study
children's language acquisition, we get a
lot of spontaneous data from them and we
analyze it. And the one question we have
is, if you are 13 years old and you don't
have a language system, will you develop
language like a baby or will you do
something else because you have a
developed cognitive system, we jump in the
middle of the task and how will this
progress?
To answer this question we need to look a
little bit at how normally hearing
children or deaf or hearing children
develop language when they are exposed to
it at a young age. The major hallmark of
children's language acquisition is that
they vary quickly as they are acquiring
the grammar of their language, their
sentences get longer and longer and the
reasons their sentences get longer and
longer is because they're learning all of
these, the morphology, the syntax and as
they're expressing their ideas they're
better able to use grammar to express
them. And so, these data show the average
length of children's expressions. Two of
these children are normally hearing and
acquiring English, and two of these
children are acquiring ASL. So we see that
in fact the teens that we have been
following show no increase in their
language, they're able to learn language
and put words together but in fact we
don't see an increase in their grammar. In
the last study we wanted to neural image
these children, we wanted to see what are
their brains doing with the language that
they have and so we used a magno--
We used MAG, Magnetoencephalography which
is a different technique, which is
complementary to the FMRI. And what we did
for this is we studied their vocabulary
and we made stimulate that we knew that
they knew the words that were in their
vocabulary and it looked something like
this.
In the first instance the picture matched
sign and the second instance it didn't,
and when that happens the brain goes uh-oh
and you get this M400 response and that's
what we were localizing in the brain for
these children. And because we're using
vocabulary that they have, we know that
they knew this words, we asked them to
press buttons and while they were doing
this task and we knew that they were
accurate. We didn't only test these
children we also tested control groups, so
some of these control groups are deaf,
some are hearing, some are first language
learners and some are second language
learners. The first panel shows the
response of a group of normally hearing
adults doing this task while looking at
pictures and listening to words, and this
is data that Katie Travis used also to
look at young children's development--
neural development.
The second panel, these are deaf adults
who learned ASL from birth. And you can
see that their processing is very much
like the hearing adult who were speaking
English primarily left hemisphere in the
language areas with some support or help
from the right hemisphere. And actually,
these patterns are indistinguishable. Both
the hearing adults and the deaf adults
learned language from birth even though it
was in a different form. What's this last
panel? These are college students who are
normally hearing, they have been learning
sign for about three years which is about
the same amount of time that our cases
were learning language. So we see that
responding on this task in speech or ASL
whether it's a first language or second
language, so long as the subject had
language from birth looks fairly similar.
What about the cases, we were able to
neural image two cases and you can see
that their neural processing patterns are
quite different and they look neither like
second language learners nor do they look
like deaf adults. These children have been
signing for three years and they had no
language before they started to learn how
to sign. You can see primarily that
there's a huge response in the right
hemisphere and the Occipital and Parietal
areas. One of the subjects also show some
response in the language areas. We can see
that even though they are acquiring
language, they're doing it in a very
different way and their brains are
responding very differently. So we see
that, in fact, that there are huge effects
of language environment on both the
development of language, but also how the
brain processes language.
So we see that it seems to be that the
human language capacity, both
understanding language and expressing
language, but also the brain's ability to
process language is very dependent upon
the baby's brain being exposed to or
immersed in language from birth. And it's
through this analyzing language and
working on the data that it's being fed,
that in fact I think that the neural
networks of language are being created. So
language is a skill that is not innate,
but emerges from the inner action of the
child with the environment through
linguistic communication, and that was
probably the answer that Itard was looking
for and might be the reason why Victor did
not acquire language. Thank you.
[applause]
♪[music]♪